hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
i'm a property investor and in this
video i'm going to be answering
your property investment questions so
comment your questions below
i'll do my very best for them also if
you're not subscribed to the channel
subscribe
turn the notification bell on and also
smash the like button
so to be honest this week um i've been
getting so
many questions of the same question i
i've had probably this question about a
million times i don't know where my
laptop is i'm on my i'm on my mobile
phone
um did you really fail your financial
freedom challenge
are you putting out the full video still
listen i've had a tough week i've had a
tough few weeks did i really fail the
financial freedom challenge
yes we did fail the financial freedom
challenge in manchester
in terms of lawton the guy i was helping
to become financially free
did not become financially free we tried
to get rent to rent deals it didn't work
it was a disaster however we did i
don't don't make assumptions until you
watch the video we are putting the full
video out it's going out on tuesday so
that's in two days time
in 48 hours it's going to be out you're
going to see us fail
you're going to see us cry but you're
also going to see us win in other areas
so
we failed the initial outcome which was
for him to become financially free
it was a lot of heartache um but
yes we are going to be putting the full
video
out soon all right next is it bad to get
deals
direct to vendor as i'm struggling with
agents at the moment
that's exactly what happened to us
during the financial freedom challenge
is that we struggled with agents and
i think it depends what kind of deal
you're trying to get if you're trying to
get a rent to rent deal
getting a rent to rent deal from an
agent is not impossible in fact it's not
even hard
i just don't know what happened that
week i think one of the things that
happened was
because we're in a lockdown some of this
we just got into a lockdown when we did
that financial freedom challenge
some of the smaller independent agencies
were closed
and the ones that were open the big
corporate ones
we're just like no we don't deal with
rental rates no we don't do corporate
let's like that
they just weren't having it and we
didn't have time we i'm not making
excuses because
we tried our absolute best but when
we're trying to call people on gumtree
and open rent and spare room they were
like saying oh maybe we could do an
appointment next week but it was just
tough and horrible so anyway i keep
reverting back to
my pain and anguish about the financial
freedom challenge you definitely need to
watch it it's coming out on tuesday um
it's going to be the rawest one i
haven't been involved in the edit at all
i haven't seen any of the footage yet
apart from the stuff that you've seen
like yesterday's video but to answer
your question
uh is it better to get deals direct to
vendor it's easier to get deals direct
to vendor
but it's better to go through an agent
because if you go through an agent and
you build some trust with them
the floodgates will open because they've
got an abundance of deals it's almost
like when you get a deal from an agent
it's harder to turn the tap on
you could give up but if you do manage
to turn the tap on
the floodgates will open whereas from a
direct to vendor
you just have to go and keep walking
back and forth to the tap
i'm thinking of going to university but
i've heard you say it's bad
my mom really thinks i should do it but
i'm not sure what should i do
um i wouldn't say i say bad i don't say
university is bad what i say is
it's very simple don't listen to me
don't listen to your mom don't listen to
anyone
that's trying to tell you what you
should do with your life
that's my that's my opinion you have
your goals and then there's vehicles
that will get you to your
goal my goal is to become a
multi-multi-millionaire property
investor and to inspire lots of people
and to leave a legacy
that's my goal so i'm going to use
property as a vehicle to help me get to
the goal
if your goal is to become a doctor or a
lawyer or
a technician or an engineer then go to
university if that's your goal if your
goal is to become
financially independent through property
it's not gonna help you
i spoke to people that have spent four
or five years at uni
and studied property construction all
this stuff they come out
completely financially [ __ ]
haven't got the first clue about
property investments
they just know about all the technical
stuff that goes in the windows
of the product like it's like what so
but for
to be an engineer
so it depends on what your goal is and
what your outcome is my opinion is
university is not bad but it's massively
overrated
i wish i'd dropped out of school sooner
i dropped out of school at 16 years old
it didn't do me any good because it
wouldn't help it not helped me get to
where i'm going to you know so
don't listen to anybody though you do
what's right for you
and if you think you want to be a doctor
go and spend some time with some doctors
and see what their life looks like and
how much money they have and how much
freedom they have and how happy they are
do some work experience and then really
reassess if that's what you want to do
and if it is
then go to university you want to become
financially free through property you
probably
don't need it that's my opinion all
right next
how do you find a good deal saucer
because i want to invest but not sure
what to buy
you don't find a good deal saucer if you
don't even know what to invest in if
you're like i don't know what to buy
a deal source is going to flog you what
they happen to have in stock
no different from an estate agent so you
you shouldn't go to a deal saucer unless
you're smart educated
financially literate you know what you
want to invest in
you know what your strategy is you know
how to do it yourself but you just
haven't got the time
and then you go to a deal source and say
this is what i want
these are the numbers i'm looking for
this is the area i'm looking for
can you please now go and find me what i
want and then you can pay a deal source
so if you're not at that point
then you don't need to pay a deal
sorcerer you need to get educated and
you need to get
an understanding of what you want to do
because everyone's got an agenda
letting agents have got an agenda
normally just to please their boss but
then their boss has an agenda
and ultimately the owner has an agenda
and that's to do what probably
to get you to buy a property for them to
manage the property
and the mortgage broker has an agenda
and an accountant has an agenda
the accountant's agenda believe it or
not might not necessarily be to save you
tax
it might be for you to pay them money
they'll tell you to sell
multiple companies oh samuel you're so
cynical well
i'm just saying everyone's got a gender
i've got an agenda for making this video
right now
what's my gender my agenda is to see
people become financially free in
property
and to be part of their story so that
when i die
people remember me and my message i've
made enough money that's my agenda
everyone's got an agenda some are good
some are bad some are just neutral some
are selfish
figure out what their agenda is you go
to a deal sorcerer their agenda's going
to be to sell you a deal
you need to go to them knowing what you
want i really want to become financially
free but there seems so much to do
and so many books to read how do you
deal with procrastination
and staying focused look
i don't even know how to answer that
question i mean you're right
there's an influx of information and
opinions
and books and conflicting books you'll
read millionaire next door you're
getting all excited and you're thinking
right
and then grant cardone goes and says
that's a terrible book
you don't want to be a millionaire next
door and you're like oh man i've just
wasted all this time
and you and you're chasing the wind and
you're reading these articles and
reading these
i i would say you know you just you've
got you've got to stick to one path
um you probably need a coach or a mentor
because
because you might be thinking oh i've
got to do this this this but human
nature
will be to do the thing that actually is
easiest
not the thing that's hardest so you need
someone to hold you to account
your goals and and you need to really
remind yourself why you're doing this
it sounds to me like you know that's it
you say you know i really want to become
financially free but there seems to be
so much to do
that's what i was like the very very
beginning of of your question is flawed
i want to i really want to become
financially free but oh there seems like
a lot to do though
maybe you're not out to become
financially free and and is
you personally you say financially free
is easy well everything is easy
everything is hard it's a very
subjective thing to say
being rich is easy being poor is easy
because if you're poor you don't really
do much you know but then it's hard
because you can't pay the bills
everything is easy everything is hard
being fat and being slim being rich
being poor working a job having a
business
it's very subjective financially but
becoming financially free simple but it
does require a lot of work and if you're
not prepared to put the work in
then you need to remind yourself why are
you doing this
um and there's conflicting information
so maybe maybe
maybe just follow one one course of
action you know don't get blown by the
wind
i'll do drop shipping and i'll do
bitcoin and i'll do this and i'll do
this and i'll do this
and you end up doing nothing because if
you try and chase two rabbits
at the same time you catch nothing so
you just gotta focus
get someone to hold you to account geez
i'll hold you to account join samuel 365
every every single week on a wednesday
at 8 p.m we're jumping on a call
and you've got peer pressure now
positive peer pressure of other people
that are winning and saying how did you
do though
how are you getting on this week um
anyway all right next
i'm looking to sell my house which will
give me a hundred and twenty thousand
pounds
cash and then buy a new place that i can
add value to by extending the side and
creating an extra two bedrooms that i
could rent out for a profit
is this a good plan because i'm worried
i'll start getting hit with tax bills
i've also been watching your videos for
two years and they're very informative
but i don't know
if it will just be too much hassle
similar kind of thing but
in your case though is it a good plan
i think i think what you're saying is
you're about you you're just selling
your house now which is going to give
you 120 cash
and then you're going to go and buy
another property where you're going to
extend it
and then rent out the rooms that you
extend assuming that you can add value
in doing that
you're talking about tax dude you won't
even be taxed
because i mean of course there's taxing
everything there's tax when you put
petrol in the car
you know you're paying the the money
that you're paying for petrol actually
there's tax in that but if you're
personally if you
if you're going to be extending the
property and adding value
and even the house that you're living in
now where you're going to sell it and
get 120
if that's your home residence and you
sell it and make 120 you
probably aren't going to be paying any
capital gains tax on that now listen i'm
not an accountant
so i can't give you tax advice i don't
know your situation from adam but if
you're buying a house
that you're living in and you're
extending it or you're
you're selling it you won't pay tax on
that and then you're talking about
renting the two rooms out
if you're putting two people you won't
pay taxes on that either
because you get bedroom relief tax
unless you're making more than seven
thousand or seven and a half thousand
pounds you'll pay zero tax
so don't worry about tax anyway it's
such a poor mentality when people say
i don't want to make too much money
because then i'll end up having to pay
tax don't worry about that but you
you'll probably end up finding you
weren't paying any tax or very very
little
all right last question i'm trying to
get a rent to rent deal but not sure
what to say when i phone the agents
please could you give me your words
i don't think you want my words right
now because because
because yes you have to know what you're
saying and you have to be skilled
but trying to get a rent to rent deal is
yes it is about the words but it's also
a numbers game you need to keep going
again again again again some agents
just will not give you a deal it's
against their
policy regardless of how well scripted
you are i literally gave it my
everything to get a rent to rent in
manchester when i was on my financial
freedom challenge
i went to pretty much every single
estate agency and letting agency
in the whole of manchester we probably
went to about 44
different agents and we didn't get a
deal so i'm not really in the mood to
answer that question right now because i
just feel a bit
crappy about the whole situation um
i can we even considered not putting out
the footage on youtube
we considered the whole documentary with
lauren even though
when you when you watch it you're
probably going to be surprised because
maybe i've been a bit too negative about
it but i was just so
bummed out with what happened with the
rent and rents and with the lack of
financial freedom and stuff that we got
it was it was painful and you'll see
what
happened and what went wrong but you'll
hear my scripts you'll hear what what
you should be saying on the video
it's coming out on tuesday at 7 pm let
me know if you're going to be watching
it as well let me know in the comments
also if you've got any questions at all
comment below and i'll always tell you
the absolute truth at least from my
perspective i'm not going to try and
sugarcoat anything
i'm not going to make something sound
too complicated just so that i make
myself look clever i'm clever i'm just
going to tell you straight
i'm not going to make something look too
easy
in a misleading way i'm just going to
tell you straight and hopefully you'll
win
and when you win hopefully you'll credit
me hopefully you'll become a
member of samuel 365. samuel 365.com
check it out i'll leave a link in the
description
hopefully you'll come down to the crash
course hopefully you'll watch the video
on tuesday but all i can do is just keep
putting out content
keep doing it i've had a lot of deals go
wrong this week i've had things fall out
of bed i've had some problems
you know if you hit the rocks be a
lighthouse for others but i've also had
some massive wins over the last 12 years
of being in property and i've done some
incredible things starting from nothing
i'm going to share that as well
and if i can just help one person in
their property journey by doing these
videos
it's worth it so i'm going to keep doing
it keep asking questions i'll keep
commenting
subscribe to the channel i hope you like
the channel smash like
and i'll see you tomorrow but tomorrow i
think i think tomorrow's going to be the
trailer of the financial freedom
challenge in manchester
and then tuesday 48 hours boom shaka the
whole thing for you to see
so don't forget when you subscribe turn
the notification bell on i do not want
you to miss that video on tuesday
hey thanks for being a subscriber i'll
see you real soon